Welcome back everyone its charlie big
news they just announced a new Star Wars
series that's going to premiere next year
big surprise so I'll explain what's
going on where it's going to take place the
characters that it'll follow in where it
fits in the timeline with the
Mandalorian season 2 the obi-wan Kenobi
series the rumored ahsoka series and all
the other upcoming shows that Star Wars
is making for Disney Plus of course
we'll do some episode videos for it when
it does drop so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's a whole bunch more
Mandalorian season 2 episodes coming up
really soon in a couple months anyway
i'll number of these and talk about the
easter eggs as we go along just to keep
things organized but big stuff first the
series is literally called the bad batch
so it'll follow clone force 99 after the
events of the Clone Wars immediately
after the events of the Clone Wars so it
also takes place after the events of the
Clone Wars finale with that time jump
season 7 episode 12 anakin skywalker
having fully become darth vader and come
to look for sokka's ship with more the
clones and just found the wreckage with
her lightsaber that she left behind if
you miss some of this you're not sure
who clone force 99 is who those
characters are it's hunter wrecker
crosshair tech and now echo the cloned
that they rescued during that first arc
of the clone war season 7 now it makes
sense why they spent so much time with
the bad batch at the beginning of the
season because they knew that they were
going to do a spin-off series set around
them during this period in the galaxy
right after order 66 in the end of the
Clone Wars so just to be clear when they
say it takes place after the Clone Wars
this takes place way after order 66
order 66 happens then a little while
later the Clone Wars ends so it takes
place before the events of a new hope
also before the events of the Star Wars
obi-wan series also before the rumored
events of the Star Wars ahsoka series
they haven't really said when that's
going to take place in the timeline but
it's supposed to be Rosario Dawson's
version of ahsoka so with the bare
minimum it has to take place sometime
either after Star Wars rebels or after
the Star Wars obi-wan series and since
it takes place right after a lot of
what's happening right here a lot of the
other Star Wars Clone Wars characters
will pop up who survived the end of the
war and order 66 in terms of the other
clones so you have ahsoka obviously in
wrecks because they totally made it out
Rex
showed up on Star Wars rebels is an
older version of Rex they also revealed
in real life as of the events of the
Mandalorian season 2 Temuera Morrison is
going to be cameo iing as Boba Fett
because Boba Fett is a clone of Jango
Fett that he raised as his son Temuera
Morrison played Jango Fett so of course
Boba Fett would look exactly like
Temuera Morrison when he grew up but
because they're doing live action ahsoka
and Rex was confirmed to have survived
to this time period a lot of people are
also feeling like Temuera Morrison
will also eventually show up on the
Mandalorian as a live-action version of
Rex - will also probably see more Darth
Vader more Emperor more Imperial
Stormtroopers obviously in this new
series and of course Darth Maul who at
this time right after the Clone Wars was
busy rebuilding his criminal power base
with a shadow collective in crimson dawn
before the events of solo a Star Wars
story in that post-credit scene so it's
also probably safe to say that the
series will take place before solo a
Star Wars story there were also some
very young versions of Star Wars rebels
characters in the final Clone Wars
episodes like Kanan so older versions of
those characters might also show up who
aren't quite as old as they are when we
get to Star Wars rebels Kanan just being
the best example because we know he was
confirmed at the end of the Clone Wars
here and because it's brand-new assuming
that nothing goes wrong they'll probably
try to get at least four to five seasons
with around 10 to 13 episodes per season
similar run to the Clone Wars season 7
not a ton of episodes but it's Dave
Filoni he has total creative control
he's executive producing his show
running so it should be pretty solid but
they haven't shown off any test
animation or anything like that yet I'm
assuming because Star Wars Celebration
was canceled later this year because of
the virus they would have shown us some
sort of teaser at that because if the
series is ready to premiere next year
they're probably pretty far along with
animation and production because this is
just a teaser announcement they didn't
reveal the official release date because
assume that I still sort of in flux but
I'm assuming it'll be at least by next
summer if not by next spring what I'm
hoping is is the animation will be just
as quality as the final arc of Clone
Wars that's a high benchmark to set
though and it was kind of a special case
because you could tell that's where they
spent most of their budget because it
was kind of like a movie just broken
into four parts the whole reason they
use the special intros for those final
Clone Wars episodes
because they were intended to cross over
with Revenge of the Sith and give you
all the moments from that movie all the
story but from ahsoka and the clones
perspective Anakin's fall turned to the
dark side being anointed as Darth Vader
and of course order 66 probably the most
important event in the clones lives next
to the actual war itself and revealing
the final fate of Darth Maul because
there's so much Darth Maul that shows up
later in the timeline surprisingly hard
to kill very hard to kill Dave Filoni
himself is also still an executive
producer on the Mandalorian series he'll
stay on that for a while a lot of people
feel like eventually if things go well
he will eventually take over Star Wars
or do a live-action Star Wars movie
himself - maybe even a live-action of
Sokka movie for those of you asking
about the Mandalorian season 2 trailer
that'll probably drop sometime in August
the series is pretty much ready to go
they're just polishing some of the
post-production on it
the episodes will start premiering by
mid October there's a bunch of Marvel
Disney Plus series they haven't
confirmed the release dates for two but
that's also coming later this year so
there's a bunch of really really big
programming coming up some really cool
stuff and if you didn't see it probably
one of the best Dave Filoni clips of all
time talking about Star Wars came out of
the mandalorian so this is him talking
about the duel the fates and why it's so
important to the Star Wars story in what
Star Wars itself is all about it's
amazing so listen to this prequels I
thought were almost an impossible task
how do you tell the story that we've all
grown up with imagining who Anakin
Skywalker was in Phantom Menace you're
watching these two Jedi in their prime
fight this evil villain Maul couldn't be
more obviously the bill villain he's
designed to look evil and he is evil and
he just expressed that from his face all
the way out there the type of lights
every fights with what's at stake is
really how Anakin is going to turn out
because qui-gon is different than the
rest of the Jedi and you get that in the
movie and qui-gon is fighting because he
knows he's the father that Anakin needs
because Corrigan hasn't given up on the
fact that Jedi are supposed to actually
care and love and that that's not a bad
thing the rest of the Jedi are so
detached and they've become so political
that they've really lost their way and
Yoda starts to see that in the second
film but qui-gon is ahead of them all
and that's why he's not part of the
council so he's fighting for Anakin and
that's why it's the duel of the fates
the fate of this
and depending on how this fight goes
Anakin is gonna his life is gonna be
dramatically different so qui gonn loses
of course and he's left with obi-wan
obi-wan trains Anakin
at first out of a promise he makes a
qui-gon not because he cares about him
when they get a nakum they find him on
Tatooine he says why do I feel like we
found another useless life-form he's
comparing Anakin to Jar Jar excuse me
and he's saying this is a waste of our
time why are we doing this why do you
see importance in these creatures like
Jar Jar Binks in this ten-year-old boy
this is useless so he's a brother to
Anakin eventually but he's not a father
figure that's that's a failing for
Anakin he doesn't have the the family
that he needs he loses his mother in the
next film he fails on this promise that
he made mother I will come back and save
you so he's left completely vulnerable
and Star Wars ultimately is about family
so that moment in that movie which a lot
of people I think diminished into just
all just cool lightsaber fight but it's
it's everything that the entire three
films of the prequels hangs on is that
one particular fight and Maul serves his
purpose and at that point died before
George maybe bring him back but he died
and that's it showing you again how the
Emperor is completely self-serving he
doesn't care it's just a tool and he's
using people and I was gonna use this
child that follows all the way through
to the line which terrified me as a kid
when the Emperor tells Luke you like
your father are now mine isn't it so
cool listening to him talk about Star
Wars he totally gets Star Wars that's
why anytime he works on a series like
the Mandalorian or any of his animation
I always get really excited really the
only thing that he's been associated
with recently that I wasn't super huge
fan of was that Star Wars resistance
animated series just because I really
really did not like the animation style
hopefully this new bad batch animation
style won't be too different from the
Clone Wars but it does sound like it's
going to be just a little bit different
if you haven't seen any of those bad
batch Clone Wars episodes it's basically
the first arc of Clone Wars season 7
it's all on Disney Plus so you can go
watch it right now but I'll do more
videos for the series when they start
releasing some more footage there were a
couple other big trailers that just drop
so of course I'll do videos for that and
I'll do more Mandalorian season 2 videos
when we get more info
about that everyone click here for all
my Mandalorian season 2 teaser trailer
videos and click here for my brand-new
Mandalorian baby Yoda video thank you so
much for watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!